how would you describe dune in the
sentence out of curiosity
[Laughter]
very good
imagine star wars but good
i love star wars but there's only two
films in the series they're good the
first one the second one that came out
at 1990 1977 19.
oh yeah
yeah yeah you say first and second
one
i was like jesus christ dude i love the
first and second film all the prequel
memes oh yeah they're pretty good
threesomes
are the best memes the third one's all
right but like yeah june is like imagine
star wars but good i actually agree with
you i like the characters really not a
fan of star wars at all you know the
best thing about star wars was the lego
games that was the best thing about star
[Music]
wars they were [ __ ] amazing
i don't i've played all of them but like
the first one was so good i remember i
had the act uh i think it was four to
six movies yeah yeah you did like the
trilogy and i was my only experience for
the movies for like the first 10 years
of my life and i used to [ __ ] love it
just love getting this [ __ ] i think
the only the only thing i liked about uh
episode one was the pod racing scene gal
gang now this is the worst part
yeah
let's just stop let's just stop talking
about star wars we clearly don't know
our [ __ ]
that's from a normal perspective i
thought it was all right
i think the problem was i you know i did
like star wars a lot then the new films
came out and destroyed everything and it
was just i haven't seen anything
so [ __ ] boring it was rogue one that
was uh that was all right i quite like
that because that's sort of i mean if
you're a fan of the original star wars
film ties in nicely and the cat i didn't
care about the characters when they died
i was like
darth vader isn't it so it's good isn't
it
there's some cool scenes in it that call
back to the original and i like that but
like the new film is just just [ __ ] now
the characters i thought like i thought
the first film had potential and then it
just lacked a coherent direction i
thought well they just sort of made it
up as they went along yeah that's what
it felt like
what's that chinese whisper game when
you write a line fold it and move it on
it's like that yeah do it you want ryan
johnson i love ryan johnson but like
yeah
there was no coherent strategy yeah he
was never going to please what the fans
wanted they had they had such lofty
expectations
well it's just funny
didn't they and then the last one they
were like just do over the fans one and
it was just really really bad that's
because nothing was set up no everything
was set up ryan johnson like tore it
down did his own thing and then they
were like well no that would have worked
though if they'd had another follow-up
to that mate yeah yeah
it wasn't yeah it was like i think
definitely the second film
depended on the third film following on
from what he had set up but obviously i
mean it was just telling that like i
remember how much hype there was for
episode seven like yeah it was [ __ ]
everywhere seven was pretty well
received people were lost yeah yeah and
then of course but then like but then
every subsequent film there's just less
and less talk about it right everyone's
like oh no
i don't know and i didn't hear anything
about nine yeah number eight because
they set up eight so badly right yeah
carrie fisher the uh she
did princess leia flew through space
[Music]
[Laughter]
i could feel like the star wars fan just
like perk up when i said death star
but
the worst bit
was the like the opening like five
minutes i knew it was [ __ ] yeah
because there's a scene i don't know if
you've seen it but like there's a your
mum joke in it are you serious yeah yeah
yeah there's like the main villains
there and he's like destroy the planet
and this guy's like got a message for
your mum and it's i'm not you're [ __ ]
making this up go and watch it and i was
like episode seven they tried to get
like that marvelous humor
and it's just so bad
oh what do you think about them using
actors that are like they've passed away
and they're like putting them in the
films
uh as long as it's done tastefully i
don't mind it so weird about it though
isn't there i mean when you die i'm
gonna use you
cgi seed even if they're like yeah keep
using me i think it's just strange that
you're i mean i feel like it's it
depends on the manner that it's done
right i mean there's a difference
between
putting a beloved character in their
beloved franchise again as like a cameo
or something um and then there's using a
dead man's twitter to promote an nft
that's that's you know it's like i just
feel like disney is not the company you
want being in charge of when dead people
can keep being in films yeah yeah
i feel like dizzy's gonna be like no
harrison ford hasn't died yet
he's going to keep alive and well look
at him we have a signed note that says
he wants to keep being in star wars
infinitely
he's got a signature on it we have the
estate of harrison ford agreeing that we
wanted him being hide solo for life you
can tell immediately though when it's
done in like a milking manner though and
like i don't know fans fans are
immediately i think i i feel most fans
immediately can recognize they're like
yeah that's a thing i worked in one i
think with uh graham off tarkin and um
and uh princess leia
become like a common thing that is like
used very often yeah
do you feel like it will get a little
weird when have you seen it and thought
no this is not good it's not that i've
seen it and it's not good i'm like oh no
people are going to take this too far at
some point like just make a whole film
with the man who's dead because their
their state said sure it's like
it will happen i know it will
that's why it's kind of
i mean the music industry is already
[ __ ] there like with like all these
[ __ ] posthumous albums that it's
horrible how would you feel though like
you know 10 15 years if you die
and then you're the connoisseur
his cholesterol is pretty bad
states like we want to keep connors
connor would have loved to have been in
more videos in crane something
there's something sad about art when you
just have to bring people back from the
dead to keep making it you know what i
mean like there's something like why
can't we just just get into the talent
have art just continue to blossom with
new generations how i feel about the
matrix form
but uh but obviously it's when
corporations know that they can keep
you know because they're already trying
to rehash as much as they can the last
thing i want is that they can get the
rights to people's likeness and then
just start reproducing filled with them
well then i don't i don't think i'll be
commercially successful i i think if
someone does like go all the way then no
one's going to [ __ ] watch it
right or or they'll be just ridiculous i
feel like the industry said that about
so many things in our life and here we
are and you know
i don't know i feel i i don't know i
would like to i would like to grasp hope
and think that you know i i would love
it for us with the hope that you know
maybe people have the right to agree in
some ways
that i couldn't find i thought i thought
it was a parody account who posted it on
his account his family or something
he's going back into the
uh into stanley's twitter this isn't the
first thing that
that twitter account has promoted so
obviously someone got him to sign some
[ __ ] documents before he passed away
right just giving them rights to
basically everything because you can
control some of the state sure yeah so
you can be in control of everything
basically yeah and uh it's pretty
yeah it's pretty fun
it's pretty [ __ ] you know what's like
what's next like stan lee like deep
fakes where you
when he promotes like the newest crypto
coin
or is that your local con
jesus christ
yeah it is getting very uh very black
mirroresque you know this is yeah this
is some [ __ ] you'd see in a black mirror
episode except it's unfortunately
happening in real life
i mean i i think in our lifetime
there'll be technology where they could
go through every video we've made and
create an avatar digital avatar of us
that looks and sounds like us has the
same things
yeah but like i already have a full ai
sort of synthesized version of say
connor right so you said ai to watch
every single v8 video go for it and
listen to all the podcasts you can get
his voice you can get his mannerisms his
personality and create a sort of aic
have you not heard the gone ai voice
what what
it exists already i haven't even heard
that you haven't heard it no no oh my
god we're already there
20 years ahead of schedule
the feature is now chris the future is
now
the title of the podcast episode
the future is now
chris thought he was you know making a
making a teacher a futuristic like all
he was was just making a segway
god damn it what do you want gant to say
um
i love chris broad oh god don't do that
let me just sign up i just [ __ ] sign
up
what is this website then i don't know
how the i don't know what the ethical
requirements are to use khan's voice and
give permission for this
oh my god
[Music]
we have just hours and hours and hours
of audio from us yeah wait are you guys
on there no i'm not why am i on there
wait am i on there
uh no oh okay this is specifically me
okay
you have the least amount of videos out
of all three of us
we've all talked an equal amount of
trash too yeah so if we murder ghant now
we can have gun on the phone instead
yeah depressed
is continuing yeah it's like no there he
is
a blow up
a blow up doll with just a phone
strapped to it with john's face on it i
think that's terrifying isn't it the
year the year is 2030 all of trash taste
episodes are now auto generated
you like bone-in shits what the [ __ ]
i made like a ai system that could auto
generate some
um anime and light novel titles and it
got
these boys couldn't tell the difference
but psycho pass
something like that right
or something like that
um and now they've released like newer
updated ai they could not only make
titles but actually write a full-on like
writing prompt like started like write a
first chapter of a story
so it's all getting like pretty insane
jesus yeah and uh can i get it working
with this voice [ __ ] sign up jesus
christ
why god why only god
are you offended that you're not on it
joke no i'm just wondering what like who
else is on this why not me
who else is on this there's quite a lot
of youtubers on here really
you've made it really i don't have to
your ai now i don't have to
can just determine the difference
hold on it's synthesizing okay
synthetic
oh god
it's like it's a it's a program
a man
[Laughter]
the first one he says i love chris that
bit sounded gone yeah i love chris i
thought
that's interesting that is interesting i
think we're the future's luckily a bit
further away than yeah i thought that's
good
well it also depends on uh
how much reference they have because
they have like a spongebob voice that i
swear to god it's like a hundred percent
accurate really yeah jesus
they have chills as well and it's really
spot on
your favorite overly hard is it
number 10
lettuce
the last thing you want in your version
they went too far
[ __ ] you know i hope i'm back on that
channel one day